non bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale
tv spéciale agen 2016 aujourd'hui je
suis avec une star du sud ouest en même
temps quête d'une star du national
évidemment c'est le grand maître mathieu
cornette bonjour monsieur bonjour tout
le monde
alors un très bon début de tournoi
puisque tu viens j'ai gagné une partie
on avec les noirs ça fait toujours
plaisir face à un client et à murray
numéro 2 du tournoi
voilà il ya un peu de chance mais bon la
partie était intéressante pour regarder
et on y va
donc on entre sept partis donc entre
romain et doit et mathieu cornette alors
c'est parti je te prendrais des sujets
en fait j'étais surpris au premier coup
puisque il m'a déjà joué des 4 4 khelef
tranquille mais jamais je sais qu'un
accord mais ici en fait sur et j'ai
décidé de changer sur l'échiquier
dernière partie du jeu et qu'alexis et
ce matin j'ai regardé quelques 6 oui et
soit chic et une fille dans le jeu des
cinq à sochi quitte à changer ta pas
jouer des préparations un accord dont
ils ont mis le mythe de la préparation
du projet n'a jamais regardé beaucoup
beaucoup de choses ce matin je me suis
fait paraître 4,5 à c'était beaucoup
trop et en fait je m'étais dit qu'ils
pouvaient lever quelque chose que j'ai
regardé il ya deux jours avant de partir
au pire parce que ce qui s'est passé
dans l'arctique
donc on transpose en fait j'étais prêt à
jouer drague ouazine aujourd'hui donc ça
moi j'avais sun rising wii ou changer le
nom de soulanges l'appelle comme ça en
fait suis en train d'écrire un livre sur
la résine aleda bleus mangé au cas où il
sortira un jour et du coup je compte
l'appeler comme ça parce que je ne sais
pas comment ça s'appelle ce combat
d'idées c'est qu'on veut jouer comme une
régate in 6e 3 ça fait une ninja oui
donc la seule nine qui diffère vraiment
c'est ce qui m'a joué mais sauf que là
il m'arrive il s'est passé un truc très
bizarre c'est qui m'a jeu à trois
d'abord et donc moi je me rappelais que
de 3 km et 6 à 3 mois non la wii
d'accord ça peut paraître rien mais
savent que quand j'ai déjà joué cette
position ici imaginons cavaliers si si
si ouais tu peux jouer le coup ou alors
si on joue le coup et vous quel est
vraiment km ce qui est des six a évoqué
le 3 ça transporte dans la ligne normale
oui mais savent qu'ils peuvent 3 donc
trois mois j'ai déjà joué ses 5
j'ai déjà joué plusieurs fois mais
savent que j'avais prévu et j'ai
travaillé longtemps à la place de c5 c6
qui en vaut rare qui est joué par un ou
une finale à jouer contre 49
qu'un couple et je parlais yaw angie
mais sauf que du coup j'ai réfléchi je
me suis dit mince ici méfions prendre
sur quelqu'un prend décembre pour
longtemps il faut que je regarde c'est à
dire du parce que sinon je vais mais je
vais me rappeler de la partie c'est pas
comme l'année dernière avant l'accord en
lan j'enlève d'accor asie longues et
donc il peut être ici et là en fait j'ai
eu peur de pions pour 2,5
c'est pas un inconvénient sommet oriente
d'accord puis on prend 1,3 et du coup je
peux plus je m'aligne avec ses six parce
que l'idée de ces 6es de jouer s'éprend
des 5 peut prendre des cinq ans et c'est
pour ça que moi j'ai joué un truc je
sais même pas si c'est bon j'ai joué au
sein qui me pousse les six que donc je
connaissais pas du tout et donc là il a
joué que 3 vite donc ça transposer dans
ce que j'avais regardé avant le temps
des mets par exemple je suis pas sûr que
quatre cependant beaucoup à oui ici deux
ou quatre jeux c'est ben oui il ya aussi
à 4 x 3 qui se regardent et l' image de
trois villes de qoussair transpose de
raser tous les donneurs mais si je suis
au regret mais c'est pas elle n'avait
pas évident ça m'a fait perdre encore
dans la partie
donc du coup après on est transposée
dans ce que j'avais regardé donc d'être
auquel foot est roi c'est connu pour
être légèrement apprécié en fait et
c'est fou le nombre de questions de
subtilité que tu t'écrases et j'ai de la
chance d'avoir une course que j'ai pas
regardé ça ce matin mais j'ai regardé ça
ya trois jours mais je pense que le
maire pousse les gens à 4 qui a été
jouée par alexander pierre par exemple
récemment
caruana sinon le coût normal c'est que
la fois en fait ici soit je peux jouer à
rock b 6 x 6 le plan de base soit je
peux essayer de profiter de 52 coups
avec ça en fait lui voulait mais le
cabriolet 2 donc l'idée sexy fait pions
prononçable je fais option france 4 s'il
fait plus on prend 1,5 ici qui ont pensé
4 puis on pensait 4 et c'est bien c'est
sympa mais ça c'est bon pour les noirs
parce que tu vas en cas de prix vient tu
veux changer tu dégages à 4 et à kathak
le pion aux scènes qu'il a il a tout eu
des problèmes du coup il a joué qu'avec
les deux cas le mercou d'accord que
j'avais regarde
biatra jour 34 hockey ici je me rappelle
quand je suis allé à leur rencontre
donc je suis allé il allait en b1 ici je
pense que ces deux et plus précis
d'après mes analyses henri douard plus
tard dans la partie il va leur jouer
leur jeu mais en fait j'ai compris
pourquoi il a fait ça c'est ici en fait
ce rock il a eu peur depuis en france et
4 qu'est ce que maintenant sur le cac
les g3 y aura toro 8 mais je défends le
plus complet je me lave plus ou moins de
prendre ces quatre savons donc l' image
mais ça que je connaissais pas donc
menacé le premier coup j'ai réfléchi
vraiment et je suis rentré dans une
ligne bizarre mais bon intéressante 326
lé damas ci s'avère fort oui on l'a vu
c'était ça la gênait à manger aux gens
m'attendaient
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué je pensais que
c'était pas bon mais bon c'était
intéressant
je pensais qu'il allait je dois me 2
pour défendre le pion ouais de me deux
tours 8
et je menace de le manger mais je
pensais qu'il allait sacrifier le pion
comme ça et après ces jo f34 de jeu pour
le centre d'accord ans que c'était mieux
que ce qu'il a fait donc là il a joué à
mon avis en fait il m'a dit après le
match qu'il a fait une erreur tactique
c'est en fait il avait prévu ça en fait
ici ce qui est amusant c'est que les
blancs ici menaces puis on prend 1,4
parce que ce refuge et quatre
intermédiaires
il ya tout reprend m6 oui attaque la
dame attaque l'adar que moi mon idée
c'était ça vous n'avez pas vu il a
oublié que maintenant temps prévu 6,9 à
la dame
voilà parce que l'idée se fout g4 on
prend d'abord la tour et on comprend la
dame mais là maintenant que le cavaly là
ça marche plus mais l'art est
honnêtement je pense voir ici pour
regarder akarlina tard je pense être
mieux juste mis d'accord et là il à
l'affiché ip en temps parce qu'il
n'aimait pas ça bosse où il est rentré
dans une très fort c'est qui était pour
moi une bonne pour moi il y est dit au
développement il alors au centre
sid à l'essai de la menace de mathan ces
deux doses qui fait qu'il peut pas
bouger son cavalier envoyait déjà que là
il y avait des problèmes
donc si dame ces deux je prends du
cavalier henri iv je suis gagnant donc
ils obligés de venir la voir les jo ça
est en fait ici moi je pensais qu'il
allait je t'en prie aussi s'essayer de
sacrifier les qualités nuit on avait
envisagé ce coup effectivement conseil
c'était ça ou c'est de bouffer les
derniers pions est d'essayer de mais pas
du tout image est en poste
ouais ouais ok ici j'étais aussi tenté
de donner sacrifier à vii pour rouvrir
les lignes genre 81 84 les f-16 mais bon
je suis en fait je voyais pas ce qu'il
faisait ici simplement c'est pour
s'ajuster d'une part le problème sous
gouvernance et que tu bouffes chaque
hall de la tour mm france elle même et
j'ai toutes les cases blanches l'âge où
les cases blangy m'en fous qu'il peut
revenir ans et oui tu peux le 6 2 après
ces quatre ont des seins il a joué du
coude développement par contre là je
pense que cette phase de la partie je
n'ai pas du tout maîtrisée
pour ces huit c'est intéressant mais je
pense qu'il doit y avoir mieux
je suis sûr qu'un ordinateur je vous
montrerai
mais aujourd'hui non mais juste je sens
que c'est pas le plus précis ouais mais
en tout cas là tu tues tu vis des
déceptions banque s'était complètement
logique c'est donc la parade
honnêtement j'ai maintenant d'être quand
même si c'est encore une fois ouais faut
prendre ces mêmes ici là dans cette
position là elle est là tourcoing et six
pions prendre tour des 5 ha oui des 5 es
tu gagnes faudrait c'est un cadeau mais
bon je jouais pts 5
madame je pense que je suis oui parce
que sacrifier de qualité en l'air
effectivement qu'à chaque fois c'est
pour ça que j'ai pris beaucoup de temps
pas trop d'accord ok et ici je suis
rentré dans une tactique joli mais je
suis pas sûr d'avoir bien calculer et
honnêtement je pense que j'ai mal calcul
auquel écologique c'est fou dessins que
je suis juste mieux gelé en c4 prochain
contre les maths à quelques bijoux et ça
tacle à tour trois ou quatre banques et
le meilleur coup sûr moins ils attaquent
leucate
oui et donc la mauny dea tactique était
simple et en fait c'est sans doute une
bêtise il faut sans doute que je joue
des dames c6 lui il m'a dit après parti
qui a prénommé csu s'il voulait
abandonner trop vie ces six ans qu'il
exagère un peu
ok il faut voir comme dom c6 faut
regarder qu'à mettons cette variante
pour réfléchir qu'est ce qu'il a vu sur
quai à quai près 1 4 k et des cinq ans
ok cavalli prend 1,4 il ya car les
dessins quand même d'un tour c'est ça le
cavalier il y aura une scène qui va
arriver derrière ces cinq réponses que
c'est ce qu'il a c'est ce que j'ai
craqué l'a fait en fait ici j'ai joué un
coup jolie je vais je fous des trous un
coup d'état en guinée sera techniquement
je la suis gagnant donc il est obligé de
prendre 1 4 sinon jean teulé quasiment
mais en fait mon idée tactique j'ai mis
vachement de temps à l'avant et j'étais
content de moi c'était après 84 france
et deux au sia qui est princier ce qui
est le cas leur de gagner une pièce mais
je le dac hors des princes il ya les
problèmes si j'ai lâché trop rien fait
vous la main il ya dans mon premier
tueur prendre ah oui parce que la tour
est floue et c'est ça le pion est flou
et je veux dire le curry cloud et
saint-amarin ces deux dames francs parce
que la dame reste attaqué et si on
reprend ici on peut prendre la tour et
si tu prends m6 et si on prend et on
prend simplement la gamme ges de plus il
est en fait le bilan et une pièce de
plus ce qui a pas tord f5
tu peux pas attaquer mais deux pièces le
foot est donc en fait j'ai cru que
j'étais juste beaucoup mieux à cause de
ses ventes à prouver sauf qu'il avait vu
ce que parce qu'il a joué tempo le bon
coup d'accord donc sur faut prendre ces
deux jeunes français 2 et d5 et là du
coup je pensais juste être beaucoup
mieux jarjat option mais j'ai toutes les
lignes qui sauve mais en fait ici je me
suis rendu compte que j'ai
en fait j'ai cru que je le coup que j'ai
joué a été gagnant en fait c'est pas du
tout du tout aux gagnants c'est juste
hyper compliqué et je sais pas faut
vérifier peut-être que ses parts dans ça
a l'air bon ben ok faut toutes les
pièces qui sont quasiment ici à des
filles il ya plusieurs quoi regarde
hockey dans la peau ce qu'il a fait
n'est reparti à faire du matériel tout
simplement donc l'autre court à regarder
ces genres 3 2 pour enlever le couloir
et protéger le fou mais toi tu vas
prendre trois en trois ans je jouais
donc ici je voulais jouer demain 6 2 2 6
7 6 contre attaque sur le cavalier ou
bien sûr et derrière il ya le fouquet en
prie je menace d'un proto jeunesse d'un
premier cas à dr f4 et là il a
visiblement et life 5 allée des six je
pensais plus fera tout simplement
c'est lui qui me l'a dit après la partie
ah oui parce que la tour est en prise
oui parce que je connais ce drame sont
trois dames mais cet échec on n'a pas
peur de calais france puisque dimpre en
échec et on reprend avec échec en plus
si on ramasse où le cavaliere et dit moi
aussi îles féroé 3 ha oui qu'est prince
peut-être f5 i7 900
parce que si je fais quel point 4 il
prendre la dame pozzato oui voilà
exactement f5 la cie brune faire mon
cavalier chèque peut être mais du coup
je suis mieux stratégiquement moi j'ai
pas pu au moins
juste un super cavaliers contraindre
donc je crois que ça marche mais du coup
je sais pas ce qu'il doit jouer sans
qu'elle s'égare
faut voir peut-être qu'il a raté un truc
mais on n'a pas tous les deux on n'a pas
trouvé de défense que par grave on reste
à chaud dans l'analyse à chaud on ne va
pas regarder toutes les variantes
donc il a giflé 4 et un verre monde par
chance ça marche pour moi ou non j'ai
très bien donc je fais dame me suis donc
son idée c'est qu'il veut contre les
accusations
oui ah oui parce qu'il va intercepter le
clouage il ya tellement de mai sauf que
là je gagnais matériel de façon fort
cette attaque la tour attaque 4 donc il
n'a pas trop le choix sur votre unique
voilà il faut qu'ils donnent la gkb les
prendre
caissie fait fou proches que je m6 et je
vais gagner une pièce surtout prend rêve
si c'est qu'il ya trop de matériel sur
les colonies avec courage et là j'ai eu
un coût qui gagne mais bon je lai way
ces dames est sain en fait cavalier 6
encore une fois ne marche pas à quinze
hommes pro est le pionner club est le
pion est qu un jour pareil à le violer
la clause si on attaque le fou dont il
avala il faut le dire quand même parce
qu'elle est si ce serait une super
défense nationale la dame et la dame
attaque la dame mais on prend simplement
de la dame et le pion étant cloués sur
le roi voyez bien que je prendrais aucun
moyen de défendre le fouet au cap avant
le
qui le défend ou le bouge et en fait
l'idée c'est que j'ai tour c4 donc il
fait g3 est maintenant sur n'importe
quel coup j'aurais fait pour cette
course et clarey genou l'âge mais entre
le gagnant mais bon de là à cause du
fait que la dame le funk la veille le
cavaly clou sur la dame mais bon gagnant
avec moi ça suffit rarement à nikos et
n'importe quoi presque non mais la
finale est belle aussi petit coréen ji
technique comment s'y prendre et ça pour
nous c'est beau papier peut-être que tu
en prends un cadre déjà et plus simple
moi je me sens ok ça c'est le seul bon
coup que j'ai joués je pense que c'est
utile oui c'est bien parce que derrière
lui ça évite telma du couloir mais sur
qui en plus ça prend des cazoulins je
pense qu'il faut que je joue autour
d'eux tout simplement coupé loin et
après j'active ma deuxième tour en fait
moi ici j'ai manqué déjà j'avais pas vu
qu'ils pouvaient le frein gm
je pensais que c'était bête de l'un des
deux on va là j'ai compris que si je
joue tour à 4 il peut je e 5 e 6 pardon
c'est ça que j'ai complètement loupé si
on prend foule 5 et son fou devient
monstrueux et là ce qui va ramasser g7
avec échec et s'ils ramassent tous les
pions tuera hors du coup là c'était
panique avec deux minutes à la pendule
oui donc j'ai joué ça pour contre les
deux suisses est maintenant toi qu'a
donc et ça c'est pas complètement bête
sauf que maintenant il me fait le
chantage aux perpétuelles voilà bah
sinon je prends nul ne voulait pas ok
donc la grande question c'est est-ce que
je dois je 5 donc le 100 g 100 g sage
dans laquelle fut obligé 5 il fait faut
être fou décade
donc c'est peut-être le bon goût mais
manzai note ça j'ai un peu paniqué j'ai
un peu peur pourquoi parce que qu'ils
ont ici c'est dangereux ça allait du
coup comment tu as le droit non ça peut
être un peu dans l'ailé le roi avec un
peu dans des bureaux des réseaux
cependant il est c'est un peu long à une
enquête
je pense que j'ai 5 et le bon coup je
sais que j'en fait ok là j'ai quand même
calculé une vente bon un peu bête mais
qu'il faut noter le retour 17
s'il avait fait ça la course 3 points à
33 tandis qu'il agonise carrément
échange la cour triste 7 17
et ici j'ai que un coût qui est
l'heureux cet afflux des six échecs
si les ag
la mia torrado intermédiaires les
traders qui gagnent mais non c'est
toujours bien de voir si jamais il faut
montrer au public mais appliqué cette
salle c'est sous des six évidemment
fourchette
et si le roi prend dame ça c'est
embêtant quand même aimé en fait tout
simplement c'est si je juge autour d'eux
ici aux tourrades d'abord échec ça évite
la tour d'être pris le bras au bout ils
veulent y est c'est fini on y incarne
heureusement sinon ça perd ok j'ai
calculé ça comme mon cas ou non qu'ils
achètent aux recettes
ouais tours 7 bon ok donc là c'est le
41e
j'ai pas jeu direct or là c'est
dangereux parce qu'il ya quand même fou
ou celle qui menaçait encore doha moitié
donc là en fait j'ai calculé et en fait
je me suis rendu compte que la ligne que
je voulais jouer au début me semble est
nul et non plus j'ai réfléchi plus j'ai
l'impression que j'avais des chances de
hier donc aller forcer sein d'accor et
chez pim pim
quelles sont ses positions critiques ici
donc et les voilà je prends la glace et
la pression critiquer il faut près 1,6
c'est bête parce que je souhaite enfin
je crois
p g a besoin de plus il ya un gros un
groupe une boucle locale le notebook
critique ces tours j'ai six échecs et
gagnant d'ailleurs 1 dans la finale ça
suffit pour gagner sans cela ça surprend
un tour j'ai six échecs c'était le club
coup en fait là il a réfléchi longtemps
mais d'accord 3m 5,86 à 5
donc pour essayer de garder un pion
compte trois mon corps à 5 est en fait
le truc c'est que son choix est fait je
jouais vite à 4 gb 3 pour eux quatre
tours à deux et je vais avancer mon pied
va avancer la justice via une petite
ligne tactique et orages cinq échecs
adacore walk est calculé tout son temps
prend un s à 5 marche pas ce que j'ai
tour des trois échecs en quoi encore
beaucoup en échec intervient dire oui
l'idée c'est que sur coup franc 1 5 to
reprend au roi prend hélas c'est sans
doute nulle puisque c'est que les
allemands et c'est nul mais surtout
français ont fait tour des 3 es le roi
protège la tour du roy bouge et on
reprend la tour et 7h05 j'ai aussi rodez
4 et il ajoute au prince est cette
finale est en fait il a juste prendre
cette galère
caldera d'obtenir ok donc la cif fo
prend un schiste nul donc j'ai obligé de
jouer ça ouais et en fait ce qui est
bizarre c'est que cette position je
pense qu'elle est gagnante pour les
noirs dont elle est en fait au début je
me suis bon de sap est nulle et en fait
j'ai pas vu de défense donc là il a
ramené le roi c'est le taux logique
aurait donc appelé ici je me lasse h4
bien sûr puisque le si on prend vie dans
le foot emprise est alors l'idée de
jouer h théâtre c'est de coucher pour la
dame voilà c'est pareil pas de prendre
le cuir mais sur elle met donc du coup
on fait de la ya un truc qui est assez
intéressant à comprendre c'est que le
fou n'a pas de gaz
il peut pas l'en des six parce qu'il
éprouvait et quand il va en baby jet
tours bessette et il est obligé de
repartir
oui donc là son seul coup et il refusait
de revenir à quatre colons qui était
hilarante enraya toujours h4 qui
quitterait son seul coup c'est de
ramener le roi oui mais voilà je re être
parce que le foot n'est pas le cas donc
là est en fait là il faut savoir qu'elle
aille à deux coups qui viennent j'ai
joué le ranger 4 ouvrages et cas de gale
mais il faut savoir comment c'est pas
alors heureuses les quêtes vous faire
attention parce que sinon tu vas bien
essayé d'un parti radical ont fait les
six d'ici et là y'a que je pense qu'un
cookie guen clair ces tours 1-2 ah oui
tour ado qui empêche le roi de la
merveille ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
fouquet vite donc on continue
ah ouais tu vas venir à angers 2 n'ont
songé 2 - fait tord congé train alors
fou 16 17 et maintenant tu prends je
trouve sa 3e a donc là il faut savoir
que
je bouge la tour imaginons tour b tu
retrouves en est juste de dire en
général
moi j'ai 2 way projet 2 mais en fait
cette position est gagnante mais la
pente h 4 nuls
oui il faut pas pouvoir pour influencer
sa non en fait ce qu'il faut c'est
d'abord bien avoir déblayé le terrain
comme d'hab il faut extraire le roi doit
donc en fait on met le roi sur la
première puis on monte le sien et après
on doit passer la tour sur la colonne
j'ai sorti à leroy médiator sur la
colonne g d'accord ressortir nos trois
pouces et notre pions h
il faudra corriger la chance et je les
montre et un élève ya pas si longtemps
que la connaissez mais ça c'est
classique de finale
mais d'abord déblayer le terrain avant
de toucher le lion quoi est ce que c'est
le mot j'ai le mauvais pions avec le
plein de l'autre côté c'est gagnant
facilement mais là en fait il faut
savoir qu ici jean seb on me dira le ce
qui est pourquoi je voudrais tu as 4 h
katia des risques parce qu'en fait si le
fou à venir en h2 g13 achats il ya de
grands risques de patte de pâtes vous en
payez donc avant de gagner avant de
pousser plus riche qu'il faut sortir le
roi du coin voilà c'est ça mais bon en
fait à la fin j'ai juste un gain en un
coup enfin un coup alors on regarde
lâcher car voilà h4 donc très joli donc
l'idée c'est un peu la fête
campbell là l'idée c'est que donc
comprends je fais tu auras trop échec et
je gagne le fou bien sûr sur qui on
prend il ya échec et le roi parler le
fou est perdue donc s'apprécier mort si
j'ai quatre prendre un peu la même idée
que
alors si j'écris tout à l'heure pour
regarder roi prend il doit bouger le
foncier a pas d'autre chose il faut
bouger des six est en fait là je trouve
que je coupe le rang à vii où on a deux
voilà c'est qu'on en gagne un radeau 203
lâche 2 et on voit bien que l'on peut
pas empêcher le pion d'un client qu'il
est juif ou des six cas l'air logique
aérologiques h3 parce que je veux
surtout pas échanger les pions et
menaces h 2 donkey la mâchoire édentée
l'objet du g4 est en fait ici au roi
pranger captifs nuls après run est oui
alors faut pas faut pas faire voir à mes
yeux c'est ça on va prendre ça tienne
puisque le roi bien là et tu contrôles
age ii et qui apprécient n'en sait pas
de quoi mais en fait ça s'est super bien
je réfléchis du coup là il n'y a pas de
coups et c'est pour ça qu'elle a fait de
son problème c'est que son fois plus de
cas sur la diagonale
trois des six et bouc est donc mince on
importe quel coup ici je tourne à 2
voilà qui coupe ettu il peut pas
empêcher h dos dames j'ai même failli
abandonner le fou et au prochain coup je
fais tu auras de zeddam voilà et en
europe c'est joli aura des heureux aussi
de la partie non non je n'en suis quand
même s'il pense que non mais bon on
voyait bien comme visuellement et qu'il
avait mis la pression et à l'appareil je
pense j'ai craqué en zai note mais j'ai
réussi à m'en sortir et d'être ici
d'après le times note we be ces délits
malheureux au centre de toutes sortes
sorties toutes ces piètres multiplié en
santé mais qu'il était sous pression
quand même nom mais ça c'est bon
j'ai plutôt dominé mais pardon on sent
qu'à un moment ça m'a un peu échappé
mais bon j'ai réussi à m'en non cela se
compte en mois par abou lysiane merci
c'est quand même chouette alors toujours
entraîneur de l'équipe de france
ce joueur entraîneur de l'équipe de
france féminine féminine et la prochaine
échéance et bakou donc c'est bas coût
dans
on part le 1er septembre donc tu les
accompagnent les suivants elle avait
quand même
les joueuses de l'équipe de france à bas
coûts et des gains de ces derniers alors
l'équipe de france cette année ça va
être court alors allé en fait ce sont
les trois premiers lots de là les
françaises ont refusé la sélection ont
pas pu pour des raisons personnelles et
donc du coup la composition donc aux
lots ça doit être ce sophie millet au 1
enfin un premier lot après ça doit être
dit nomade se raser s'il ya colas andré
un impôt tesco et mat il conjugue
d'accord les lignes qui paraît assez
jeune on les regarde là ils ont sorti
avant-hier les listes on doit partir 15
ou entre 15 et la 20e place
ouais donc on part quand même loin ce
n'est pas moi c'est assez normal sans
admira sans mari ses vagues c'est normal
d'être un peu plus loin sur la liste
mais snpt et du coup on aura moins de
pression on est là pour se faire plaisir
pourquoi pas essayer d'approcher d'un
top 10 avec cette équipe c'est jouable
moisan toute une période de méforme
intéressante mais bon je sais qu'elles
sont capables de bien gérer donc faut
juste espérer qu'il sera en forme au bon
moment et moi je ferai de mon mieux pour
les aider
puis que l'ambiance soit bonne aussi je
pense que l'ambiance est très bonne vous
avez vous amuser à bakou ça va être
sympa on va vous suivre mais sûre pour
ça et puis on va te suis pour le
national août a bien démarré et comme
déjà des à tergnier tu as fait un super
national fn a pas mal quatrième c'est
quand même pas mal et cette année bon
ben était bien parti on peut dire ouais
moi demain je vais laurent avec les
noirs
donc on verra demain soir laurent qui on
sait pas le résultat encore mais il est
assez belle partie ouais mais c'est pas
sûr que ça glisse passion c'est parce
que j'en faisais pas au moment où on
parle mais on ne sait pas voilà merci
beaucoup m
mais retournons à tout le monde voilà
merci nous avoir suivi sur diagonale tv
le studio devant la tv spéciale anges en
juin agen à juin 2016 et donc je vous
donne rendez vous pour une demain pour
une autre émission avec notre joueur des
nationaux merci au revoir